In a world still reeling from the impacts of Covid
we realise that this is a difficult
time for many people here.
Fortunately, our economy has
fared much better than expected,
especially compared with
other parts of New Zealand.
This is largely because of our proximity to
Christchurch, our low reliance on tourism,
and residents shopping and supporting local.
However, we’re not out of the woods yet, and the Council
would like help the community recover by:
Keeping rates as low as possible
Supporting existing and new businesses
Marketing Waimakariri as
destination for domestic visitors
Increasing social support for
our most affected residents
And accelerating our capital works programme
by taking advantage of the Government’s
shovel ready and stimulus funding.
We will also continue to seek support and funding from central government.
Visit waimakariri.govt.nz/letstalk
to find out more.